The Beldam, commonly known as The Other Mother
was an evil entity that existed as early as
the 1700s.
It is not known when The Other Father came
into existence, but one line in the book suggests
that it was long before The Beldam created
the illusion of The Other World.
He tells Coraline: “There isn’t anywhere
but here.
This is all she made: the house, the grounds,
and the people in the house.
She made it and she waited.”
This suggests that The Other Father was around
to see the creation of the house, the rats,
the dogbat things, and the other Miss Spink
and Forcible, and in the movie, the Other
Wybie, who is not in the book.
But unlike any of those creatures, The Other
Father demonstrates a will of its own to fight
back against the influence of the Beldam.
To explore the true nature of the mysterious
being behind the facade of The Other Father,
stick around to the end of this video.
The Other World is the creepy, harrowing alternate
realm adjacent to Coraline’s home.
It was created by The Beldam, looking to feast
on the souls of whatever children it can lure
into its domain.
Everything it created was a twisted copy of
something from Coraline’s world, except
for The Other Father, who seems to have existed
long before Coraline’s real father was in
the picture.
Welcome to Horror History.
I’m gonna explore the entire history of
The Other Father, including the dark truth
seen only in the book, but before I do, I’ve
got to really, really, really quickly mention
this episode’s sponsor Raycon.
What else can I say that I haven’t already
said about the Everyday E25 earbuds?
So many of you have already voiced your satisfaction
after picking up your pair using my link for
15% off.
You’ll get 6 hours of play time, seamless
bluetooth pairing, more bass, and a more compact
design that gives you a nice, noise-isolating
fit.
Just ask some of your favorite celebrities…
Michael Myers.
The Invisible Man.
Llama Arts.
I’m out of time, but get yours.
Buy raycon dot com slash czsworld.
Link in the description.
Fifteen percent off.
Buy raycon dot com slash czsworld.
Forever.
How did The Other Father get to The Beldam’s
world?
Based on the information available in the
book, there are two possibilities.
One, is that it was actually the initial inhabitant;
it was there before the Beldam discovered
the realm and made it into her lair, killing
whatever other creatures dwelled there and
keeping this one around only to do her bidding.
The Other Father is described as a huge, white, swollen
monster, with a vague face like pale clay.
It had something that resembled a nose, and
the mouth does not appear when closed, but
opens up with sticky pale stands when open.
The skin is described similar to warm bread
dough and when Coraline meets it, it has black
button eyes, but those were probably not originally
part of it’s anatomy -- likely added by
The Other Mother as a sign that she had taken
its soul.
This leads me to the second possibility about
The Other Father’s origins.
It may have been one of the previous victims
of The Beldam.
When Coraline meets the ghost children their
souls have been separated from their bodies
and they’re no longer able to remember details
about their true selves.
What if after the The Beldam begins feasting
on the souls, the bodies associated with them
lose their detail and lose what makes them
them?
There are three ghost children whose souls
have been taken, two girls and one boy.
The Other Mother has three accomplices, two
female and one male.
Remember, Wybie isn’t in the book, and the
man upstairs is actually just a pack of rats
in human clothing.
So The Other Father may have originally been
the body of the young ghost boy, that was
sucked of its individuality by the Beldam,
and then reformed and reconfigured to look like
Coraline’s father.
The idea is backed up when Coraline has this
realization: “These things—even the thing
in the cellar—were illusions, things made
by the other mother in a ghastly parody of
the real people
and real things on the other end of the corridor.
She could not truly make anything, decided
Coraline.
She could only twist and copy and distort
things that already existed.”
When The Jones Family moved to the house,
The Beldam wanted to turn The Other World
into an ideal paradise for Coraline in order
to trick her into staying, and so, formed
herself and her prisoners into ideal versions
of the people in Coraline’s life.
The real Mr. Jones, not the one from the Counting
Crows song but Coraline’s dad, makes recipes
that are too complex for Coraline’s simple
taste buds, but chad The Other Father makes
her delicious midnight snacks and hot chocolate.
Coraline first meets her Other Father after
arriving in The Other World, andher Other
Mother tells her to go fetch him for lunch.
She finds him in his study with big black
shiny buttons for eyes.
He claims that he’s starving, and that they’ve
been waiting for her for a long time.
We know that The Beldam doesn’t thrive on
real food, but rather feasts on childrens’
souls -- so it’s possible that she made
The Other Father say this line about being
hungry just to add authenticity to the illusion.
In this analysis, I’m looking at the character
from the book, not the movie -- but the book
doesn’t tell us whether or not The Other
Father actually eats the food.
In the movie he does, whereas The Other Mother
does not, she only eats insects and souls.
“She'd just love something to eat.”
“Eat?
That ridiculous.”
Another possibility is that The Beldam is
unable to suppress her subconscious desires
from manifesting in The Other Father while
she’s controlling him.
Again, I’m hesitant to bring this up because
it’s only in the movie, not the book, but
when he sings the song for Coraline he’s
being controlled by these hands created by
The Other Mother.
“In Soviet Russia…”
“This piano plays me.”
And the lyrics of the song call her a peach,
a doll and “cute as a button”.
“She’s a peach, she’s a doll, she’s
a pal of mine.
She’s as cute as a button in the eyes of
everyone who ever laid their eyes on Coraline.”
Calling her a doll and button shows The Beldam’s
desire to take her soul and sew buttons over
her eyes and calling her a peach shows that
The Beldam sees her as a tasty snack.
“Mmm… who’s starving, raise your hand.
Whoa!
Ho, hoo!”
Again, it’s not his hands that rise, it’s
the Beldam’s hands controlling him.
But going back to the book now, the Other
Father remains mostly passive in the coming
scenes.
He helps The Other Mother clean up after lunch,
and when Coraline goes outside to explore,
he tells her they’ll be waiting for her
to come back with smiles and waves.
When she gets back, he is the one to suggest
that if she likes it in their world, she can
stay forever by letting them sew the button
onto her eyes.
He tries to assure her that it won’t hurt,
which makes her think that it definitely will.
Coraline goes back to her own world to discover
that her real parents have gone missing, so
she eventually has to return to the Beldam’s
world to try to win them back, but when she
does, she notices some strange new behaviour
coming from her Other Father.
When Coraline returns to the alternate world,
she’s greeted by her Other Mother, but her
Other Father is just strangely sitting in
a chair in the hallway before he stands up
to greet her.
The Other Mother at least does stuff; she
has things of her own to tend to.
But The Other Father is almost like an item,
just waiting to be used by her.
But it seems that her ability to manipulate
him is dictated by some kind of energy, because
when Coraline first arrives, everything is
set up perfectly to make him almost indistinguishable
from her real father.
But as she grows more and more hungry, the
cracks in this facade are starting to show,
and she’s not able to have full control
over him all of the time.
When Coraline asks why they don’t have their
own key for the door between the two worlds,
he blurts out an answer.
“There is only one key.
Only one door,” said the other father.
“Hush,” said the other mother.
“You must not bother our darling Coraline’s
head with such
trivialities.”
This is the first time he says something out
of line, meaning that her control over him
could be slipping.
He gets even weirder the next morning when
Coraline goes into his study looking for the
Other Mother.
He sat at his desk, not actually doing anything
-- not even pretending to be doing anything.
She also notices that his face looks more
vague, describing it as looking like “bread
dough that had begun to rise.”
He tells her that The Other Mother is outside
fixing the doors, so she tries to engage him
in conversation.
Instead of the usual friendly attitude he
puts on, he tells her that he’s not allowed
to talk to her, but he’ll continue to be
hospitable once The Other Mother is back.
But when Coraline tells him that she’s going
to go exploring, he accidentally slips up
and tells her there’s no point, because
the Beldam didn’t create anything further
than the eye can see.
“He looked embarrassed and he put one finger
to his lips again, as if he had just said
too much.”
He is the only character to demonstrate the
free will to say what he wants, but the Other
Mother punishes him for exercising this ability
by locking him away in the cellar underneath
the abandoned flat.
He also continues to lose whatever resemblance
he has left to Coraline’s real father, and
by the time Coraline finds him down there,
he’s swelled out into his monstrous form,
with only his voice somewhat resembling that
of the original Other Father, and his two
black button eyes, signifying he’s still
under the control of The Beldam.
She would use that control as a trap for Coraline.
At this point, the creature has had enough,
and is trying to fight back against The Other
Mother.
Coraline figures out that he’s been locked
away as punishment for his loose lips earlier,
and the creature nods to confirm.
He also tries to warn her,
“Run, child.
Leave this place.
She wants me to hurt you, to keep you here
forever, so that you can never finish the
game and she will win.
She is pushing me so hard to hurt you.
I cannot fight her.”
The movie is a little bit different.
In the movie, there’s no cellar scene and
The Other Father seems to have been crafted using
a pumpkin from the garden, but as time
goes on he loses his father-like qualities
and becomes more...
Halloween-y.
But the way he tries to fight The Beldam’s
control is very similar.
Roll it.
“Sorry.
So sorry.
Mother making me.
Don’t wanna hurt you.
Take it!”
In the book, when The Other Mother tries to
make it attack her, Coraline encourages it
to be brave, which is interesting, because
from the very beginning, The Other Mother
has been trying to make this thing into an
ideal version of Coraline’s dad.
However, it seems that the one thing she didn’t
teach it was bravery, and Coraline’s real dad
was the one to teach Coraline the concept
of bravery after this one incident where they
accidentally walked into a swarm of wasps,
and he had to stay back and let them sting
him in order for her to get away.
I guess the message here is that you can dress
someone up and make them appear a certain
way, but you can’t create bravery artificially,
that’s something that you must learn from
experience.
However, the monster was not able to hold
off The Beldam any longer.
It moved between her and the steps, cutting
off her exit and it gradually grew in size;
it’s voice becoming less and less human,
before finally it lunged across the room towards
her.
After seeing the monster looking lost after
one of it’s button eyes had fallen off earlier,
she ripped off the second eye, causing it
to roar in pain and charge the area that it
had last seen her standing, but it was too
slow.
It’s only option was to go quiet and listen...
and it could hear her tip-toeing up the steps
after her, but she was too quick and it crashed
against the trap door above as she closed
it, perhaps being forever trapped and forgotten.
Never again do we see the horror that temporarily
masqueraded as The Other Father, leaving both
its origins and its fate a mystery that I
can really only speculate on as I have in
this video.
But if not for the creature’s timely rush
of courage, our hero may have never been warned
of The Beldam’s nasty deceptions, and likely
would have been the next victim to be used
and abused by The Other Mother.
Click the video on the left for my complete
playlist of Coraline character histories,
including Coraline, The Beldam and Wybie,
and if you love horror, make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we stay inside.